Georgia State Representative makes moral
decision to leave party rep mesha Mainer
quit the Democratic party and has joined
the GOP saying for far too long the
Democrat Party has gotten away with
using and abusing the black community
that's it she's from District 56
she is uh been in since January 2021 she
ran unopposed by Republican Challenger
in the 2020 and 22 Democrat primary
elections in the state and now she's
quitting won't be it's not the first
time won't be the last time
but I have to wonder what uh what's in
store for us in 2024 if this trend
continues because the reality is we're
not seeing the inverse Trend no this
idea of Republicans jumping ship and
becoming Democrats is just not a thing
it happens sometimes but not really
typically it's neocons and people who
want war siding with neolibs who agree
with them on war but when it comes to
cultural issues like her issue with
school choice Democrats say outright no
do as you're told and she was like I'm
out I'm out I I think that that what you
mentioned about it not going the other
way that it's not really neocon or not
really conservatives or whatever I think
that they all kind of beat feet in 2016.
if they if you were like a if you were
anti-trump or whatever and you were an
establishment type Republican they kind
of had already have already left the
party and they did it years ago
um so would speak to speak to this
phenomenon of Democrats I mean you see
it
you see it in the you know in the
political space but you also see it you
know with uh what's her name Anna
kasparian
um there was another leftist that had
recently come out and and left you know
essentially left the left and a lot of
it is because they find out that the
narrative that is spun by the left
generally does not map onto the truth or
doesn't map on re onto reality
um and
there are going to be people that are
going to disagree about the places where
it doesn't map onto reality but I think
that the LGBT issues when it comes to
transitioning kids is where the breaking
point for most people are it's like look
you cannot you cannot have trans kids
you cannot have kids that are
prepubescent that you're encouraging not
just allowing but encouraging at times
to live their lives as if they're a
different uh you know as if they're they
have they're biologically different that
is unacceptable to the mass majority of
the uh of the population and I think
that that's starting to show when it
comes to
you know I don't know the specific
reasons that uh that rep what's her name
rep what Maynor Misha Maynard yeah I
don't know why she specifically left I
don't know you know I haven't read her
specific story school choice was the big
issue she wanted parents to be able to
she she was concerned that many of these
schools were so awful that these kids
were struggling to learn how to read and
that parents would have a right to take
their kid and put him in a better school
and the Democrats were like no shut your
mouth see and that should be something
that is is
that should be something that is is
really important to especially poor
communities and communities that have
have kids that aren't you know making
they're graduating with with a third
grade or fourth grade reading level like
that is a huge concern and that's
something that you hear about all the
time so I I you know more power to her I
think that that's something that more
people should be concerned about
absolutely agree there are a lot of
issues that people say shouldn't be
political and most of the time when I
hear that phrase I roll my eyes it's
like well too bad it is political that's
how this country works we have one party
that's heinously evil
um not to say every individual person in
the party realizes that but yeah what
the party wants is disgusting and
horrible and will destroy the country
but when it comes to school choice I
just want to finish this thought when it
comes to school choice it is it's so
obvious from any framework from any
framework that this is the right thing
let parents choose where they send their
kids to school don't force kids to stay
stuck in failing school systems now I
don't know why I would have the
expectation that people who think it's
okay to groom and mutilate kids and kill
born babies would see that also maybe
parents shouldn't be forced to put their
kids in failing schools but even without
those other two questions that people
end up being tied up with their party's
language on and not examining critically
with the school choice stuff you just
got to think it's whenever they say
things like
you're going to destroy or defund the
public school system what they're
acknowledging is parents would choose
anything besides the public school
system if they had a choice so even
their own arguments against school
choice or arguments for school choice I
wanted to say real quick uh
up until recently both parties were
discernably evil yeah and then you had
this Insurgency with Bernie and with
Donald Trump and then Bernie uh showed
himself to be quite a bit duplicitous
and Trump showed himself to be
particularly anti-establishment in some
areas and so what you end up with now is
a lot of people of influence in the
Republican Party who oppose War who
oppose these things that are objectively
evil and uh objectively evil and
adjectively evil and now you have still
the neocons trying to claw back power in
the Republican party to once again
restore the two massively evil
machines in this in this country yeah no
well I think you're right that all the
elements of the Republican party that it
ended up shedding during the Trump
administration at least the bad elements
are ones that people want to restore I
think there's things the Republican
party uh shed as a result of the Trump
Paradigm in him taking over the party
that I don't think the Republican Party
should have shut I think the Republican
parties become too socially liberal but
when it comes to the Warfare issue oh
yeah I mean I'm it's one of his greatest
accomplishments was pushing the neocons
into the Democratic party yeah who was
it was it Mike Pence recently somebody
some Republican was like we don't care
about culture War issues they're stupid
I saw that yeah who was that I don't
remember we care about economic issues
it's like that's you're so wrong but oh
firstly firstly the two are unbelievably
closely linked that this is I understand
sometimes we want to separate issues
into economic issues and social issues
and sometimes that can make sense but
broadly speaking it's not possible it's
really not possible
um your social views are going to inform
your economic views I don't understand
how that could possibly not be the case
but even so to say well you know like
I'm really interested in slicing the top
marginal tax rate by three percent
um and I'm not concerned by the fact
that children are being abused and
systemically groomed through this
horrible school system I disagree I
disagree Jimmy Dore has left a lot of
economic stuff but not on a bunch of
other weird creepy stuff sure no I I
totally agree but I think that he would
tell you that his moral vision for
America is holistic and combines his
economic and moral perspective yes even
though I would disagree with them right
on how he applies those principles you
take a look at this uh mesha Maine or
democrat who's now a Republican and this
is a good example of someone who's like
yo I I disagree with this one issue and
they say basically get out of the party
the Democratic party is basically the
party of are you in the cult or not and
anybody not in that cult is right wing
it's is this how the media Works kind of
hilarious I mean you can you can think
about it in any in any context Jimmy
Dore
the dude advocates for very socialist
policies they'll call him right wing
however considering he is fairly
socialist on a lot of issues they
struggle with it you take a look at what
how they refer to me liberal on on most
on on many issues traditionally not
modern leftism and they'll say that's
right wing because the only thing that
matters and what this Democrat is
realizing either you march in lockstep
with the cult
or you get out
yes
I don't care what they call me I'm not
martial arts step with them have you
guys seen the video where they're all
holding their hands up and they're like
I will respect my black brothers and
sisters you never saw that one let me
pull that one up it's such a blatant
virtue signal it's a cult bro I'll
mention this
um you know the Democrats will say if
you disagree with us on like point five
percent of our values you're in evil
fascist or whatever the right I think is
has become far too inclusive on the
other end where we just say anyone what
is funny what the left says is if you
disagree with the left on point five
percent of anything you're down on the
left and we say and you're on the right
it's like no no no no no no they're not
necessarily on the right just because
the left doesn't like them it's not to
say we can't work with them on the the
area where there's agreement it's just
to say we have to have some way to
define these terms like just because the
left is way too strict and purist
doesn't mean that we abandon principles
let me play this clip yeah
I would use my voice in the most
uplifting way possible
and do everything in my power to educate
my community
look at this
I will love my black neighbors the same
as my white ones
that's color blindness look at this look
I don't think it's a code about racism
is that a white person saying it too yes
of course of course it's like that is
the whitest group of people that I have
seen reflective that is definitely in
Vermont
worse than something like that hey it
could be New Hampshire I don't see
anyone complaining about the fact that
these are all white people either how
we're talking about that post on
Facebook or Twitter the kids Cassidy how
many videos do we need to show people to
be like yo this is a cult that's super
crazy I'm not exaggerating I'm not being
cute I'm not being derisive I'm being
factual and academic in saying the
modern left is a cult it is a large cult
yeah to be clear they're praying like
that's what they're doing they're
praying that's a prayer ceremony me
right there they have a leader up there
who's leading worship and they're
chanting but that is prayer it's the
same thing as a confession of faith and
and to Catholicism or it's the same idea
it's their their and there's they're
confessing that they're a member of that
particular no no this is like a prayer
service yeah I wouldn't yeah yeah that's
that's more or less what I'm saying this
is like when you when you go to a church
and you know the the preachers up at the
front of the priest depending on which
group of Christians you're talking about
and he's he's stating something and the
congregation repeats it I mean when
we're talking about like ancient prayers
that have a precedent and point to
something true good and beautiful that
can be a wonderful thing when we're
talking about ideological language that
was invented 10 years ago in order to
shame you for the color of your skin
well I think it's pretty creepy but
ultimately it is prayer it is prayer and
there's nothing wrong with prayer and
religion in and of itself but there is
something wrong with these prayers in
this religion because they're wrong very
wrong but dangerously wrong you need to
make a better argument than that
like the way the way I think about any
kind of true religious prayer yeah is
sort of a
name the religion that believes in a
higher power and prayer is effectively
an admission or uh uh you know in some
way
it's rooted in knowing you are not the
end-all be-all it is not all about you
exactly there is something greater and
Beyond you and there is a component of
reaching out to the universe to God or
whatever it is you believe so I don't I
don't believe that prayer in this
context is just specifically rooted to
one religion in that context you know
Sheamus you might say Christianity
Catholicism is the correct one the rest
of people are praying to nothing or
whatever
you want to describe it my point is this
this is prayer to a person yeah well
exactly so I would say that these people
are praying to a person a human one
specific yes well so so what I would say
is that obviously Christianity is
correct I think sometimes people in like
certain Pagan religion religions are
like praying to Demons or praying to
themselves or if it's someone who hasn't
been introduced to Christianity before
and they're like trying to find God you
know when they're just innocently asking
questions I think it's possible for God
to you know hear that but that said
um I think that what you're seeing here
is a kind of self-worship because these
people are able to fit in with the group
by chanting these words and it's more or
less about that it's more or less about
fitting in virtue signaling saying I'm
one of you guys I have the trendy
opinion
that's a scary video man it's very scary
creeps me out I don't like it I I you
know to be honest with you I don't mind
it because I'm hoping that there can be
some kind of uh
some something brought to the Supreme
Court to get that whole ideology
declared of religion so that way you can
have it completely and totally
quarantined from legislation
have it have it be declared a religion
so that way people can exercise their
religion they can you know live their
life that way believe what they want
just keep it completely and totally
isolated from from State power so the
government can't you know give any kind
of past laws based on any of that any of
the the ideology well I think what
people have to contend with is a problem
that has existed ever since we started
talking about a separation of church and
state which is that we have determined
that one set of moral truth claims
should be placed in this category called
religion and other sets of Truth claims
even if made about the exact same thing
because they don't openly claim that
they reference a Creator or a god are
not to be considered religious and
therefore can meddle with legal
processes the reality is these views are
fundamentally religious because in
ideology is basically just a false
religion that does an expressly purport
to worshiping any kind of God and so you
have a religion you have competing
religions but these ones because they
don't call themselves that because they
call themselves something else are able
to you know have themselves declared
legally as National or state religions
basically we we need a a good legal
understand standing of what a religion
is the Supreme Court has a I don't
Google it because they actually have a a
specific
um definition and I believe it includes
like belief in a deity or something like
that no I it couldn't it couldn't
because then Buddhism I think is out
well yeah people have argued about that
before like Buddhism because it doesn't
technically say that there are I think
some interpretations don't I'm not a
Buddhism expert
um yeah I don't think Buddhas believe in
God I think it might does it does it
depend on the Buddhist or do they all
just say there is no God because I've I
remember learning about it as an
atheistic religion but I think some
might believe that there is yeah I think
I think I think Buddhism doesn't
necessarily require you to believe or
not to believe in a higher power okay
yeah like like base Buddhism does not
like it the Buddha himself would have
said that's that's incorrect Pro because
it's a life path essentially it's not
that wouldn't be real Buddhism it sounds
saying that but uh no the the point is
that these are heretic Buddhist
essentially yes like honoring Buddha and
rubbing his belly and things with that
are our human things that have come up
later on they're not actually part of
the original core idea that Buddhist set
out when he was on Earth he didn't it
was not his thing but they would say
they're all human things though right if
they don't believe in a god
um
well they believe in Enlightenment uh
they do believe in a state of being
beyond beyond that which would be a
Kindle like heaven but again like
throwing the Bella you know that stuff
like that are human Idols that have been
created in time
I don't see anything that specifies uh
the definition it brought me to the it
was
uh autocorrecting to Scouts as in the
Boy Scouts at first
um so I'm still looking at I don't see
anything though so what do you think
when you see stuff like this
I think it should be classified as a
religion I mean it might as well be
um I don't know it's it's really creepy
to see him worshiping I mean what is it
that they're worshiping just the the
themselves yeah there's nothing else
there right there's no ethos there's no
moral structure there's no plan there's
no path it's literally just will you
repeat the words I say and then yes or
no absolutely
yeah well and I think some element of it
is also a humiliation ritual because all
right so so let's say we just take their
words I don't remember every single
thing they said but one thing is I will
like love my
um I I will love my black neighbors just
as much as my white neighbors now this
is like if someone stands you up at the
front of the room and they're like I
need you to say in front of me that like
you're not gonna go you know hurt
innocent people okay well the fact that
you're being asked that is an indictment
of you and the fact that you would take
that question seriously suggests that
you do need to answer that question uh
because we can't really be sure about
you so there's a strong element of a
humiliation ritual to this which if
you're trying to abuse people which is
effectively what happens with bad
religions and ideologies is you're just
kind of abusing your congregation well
you want to see them prove that they're
willing to humiliate themselves for you
either willing to put up with any kind
of treatment James Lindsay makes a
compelling argument that it's gnosticism
that and which it boils down to kind of
like like the the
the existing religions that people are
familiar with like your abrahamic
religions those are actually the devil
and that there is a God behind them
that's hidden from everybody
um and that God is actually imprisoned
in reality so the the gods that we know
of as abrahamic religion gods they have
they have imprisoned the real God in
reality and the God is in in everyone so
you hear people say well there's a lot
of times where people will make remarks
that they don't realize are actually
like a cult or Gnostic but when people
say God's in everybody I don't think
there's anything that's Catholic that
says that God is actually in everyone
but the agnostic religion kind of and
this is not apologic like the gnosis
like arnostic heresy almost yeah yeah
so so it's like it's as if God is in
everybody and the ideal is to have
everybody realized that they are God and
then once everyone realizes that they
are God that's the action that's the
beginning of history or the end of
History depending on the way that you
you are are describing it
um but yeah it's it's people believing
that they are God and they want to
transcend their bodies to to become one
with God or whatever and that's that's
part of why the the trans Community
transhumanism kind of mixes into it too
because they believe that their bodies
are prisons and if you talk to people on
the left a lot of times when they're
describing the way that they have their
their their their outlook on life is
they look at the world being unfair and
their bodies of prison and they're not
really free and you hear that through
the left when it comes to like oh if you
have to go to work then you're not
really free that's articulating that
they believe that their own body and
maintaining their own body is actually
imprisoning them and they can't be their
true selves because they have to go to
work and these are these are theme that
you hear the left talk and I'm talking
about the far left but these are things
that you hear the left talking about
frequently and it lines up with the idea
that it's it's a agnostic ideology or
Gnostic uh heresy yeah I mean it's
interesting there's a couple things
there and of course like we believe as
Christians that like every every human
has God's image and likeness uh on them
yeah but that's not something but it's
not saying yeah not exactly exactly um
that's basically what the devil says I
am God that's that was his claim now I
also think that you touched on a very
important point which is that in
gnosticism there's this kind of idea
that like the flesh itself is evil and
that you can transcend it in the sense
that your mind can be something other
than what your body is and it's Superior
um and the internal state of someone who
says they're a woman when they're
clearly a man must be honored above the
actual physical reality because not only
do the two not conform but the the quote
unquote spiritual reality is higher
gnosticism a little bit difficult to pin
down just because it's similar to the
New Age movement in the sense that
there's different kinds of varieties but
generally yeah I think you're right that
there's this heavy element of Gnostic
spiritualism to all of it yeah just like
this like gnosis this case of gnosis of
like you you're only your knowledge and
only your truth is the truth that
matters not objective truth there is no
objective reality yeah and I think
that's where I see it as well that's
what I think is is it's Gnostic in that
sense and one of the things that I that
I have heard people heard again Lindsay
was talking about this is that a lot of
the Gnostic uh Cults that have been have
existed in history actually kind of like
mask themselves onto existing religions
so they'll say to to Christians or
whatever they say well well God you know
you're getting this information from
from your your priest or whatever but I
know this this other part that is
actually your religion but it's a secret
part and that's where the gnosis comes
from they know this esoteric knowledge
exactly the esoteric knowledge the
secret hidden religion and it's it's
it's actually your religion but but your
whole religion not the place that's only
been hit because you've only been
getting given a little peace because the
people that are in power want to stay in
power so they only give you the little
bit I have the gnosis I have the
knowledge to give to you and it's done a
whole in throughout history Gnostic has
gnostics have used that type of argument
to infiltrate religions that exist and
and kind of you know turn like a
symbiotic relation no not a symbiote
Like A Parasite I guess well they'll do
the same thing I have the real science
science actually says biological sex
doesn't exist I can make that claim
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time